I'm in that
come on
stream doesn't get taken out before yes
corn okay
is it hypocritical yes or no
for men to watch corn but shame sex
workers
it should be good to go but it's
understandable
because they've had the woman that was
giving it to him they wouldn't have to
watch him
so they need to add it somewhere
otherwise that's when you start talking
about was it in cells I found out the
other day that word so
corn prevents in cells
at least they're getting some
yeah sometimes you need to get that off
of your body like like you know what I'm
saying you just need to get it off
I'm more for making your own for making
your own I really is there like any
studies that go over like the rate the
rate of
um are decreasing as Hub has increased I
don't know that would be so interesting
yeah
that would be oh look it up yeah do you
want to tell me um
what was the question again do you think
it's hypocritical for a man to shame sex
workers but watch corn I think that
a lot of men pretend respect women
so just as women not all not all but I'm
saying in in some in the sex industry
especially a man might pretend to
respect what you do I've had it before
um in the sense of like a man will be
like I respect what you do like big big
up yeah
as soon as they know that sex is not on
the table it's like like how'd you
expect anyone to respect you yeah
exactly modern women today and I respect
you and you'll be um at the same time
but it depends what you're talking about
like I said on my in what I've just said
posting myself in lingerie so if you if
you say that's me being a hoe then
that's your opinion okay I can't I
respect you and you still be a whole at
the same time can two things be true
yeah um I think it's down to what what
you respect
this is how we started off right the
podcast what is respect and it's like
all people at a basic level deserve
respect right so what level are you
trying to respect this hoe right like
take it there are you trying to respect
her as a wife then no are you respecting
her because you met her on the street
and we're having a conversation yes I
can respect you I can respect the buff
it's not based off of that respect isn't
basic respect isn't given off of that
right so to your basic question in
general context can I respect the Hope
Yes
Y'all gotta start acting like two things
can't be true I think that respect is
earned I think there's a basic level of
like kindness that you should treat
people with but I feel like respect is
earned at the end of the day
she had on such an important point over
here though is the idea that men are
lying for the for the sleeves
[Music]
like like today modern women today are
mostly out of line due to simps and
white Knights yes dudes just trying to
do things in order to get the butt
there's nothing more disgusting than a
male feminist it disgusts me it disgusts
me because you're putting yourself in a
place in order to increase the chance of
being with one of these women like she
ain't gonna you bro
I smashed so much because it's the man
it's it's the male feminist the early as
women
speak speak on this is why men are still
so oppressed because it's women being
out here and it's like oh but you can't
have this like you just want the
but it's like you're gonna give them the
anyways you see um women only fans
as business women especially if maybe
because some of the same business some
of your business but I mean like do you
not respect them as business women
especially
especially you know why no like because
your open on because on for the
for a consumption for the street where
you didn't earn them
it's genetics respect for you I mean I
mean a lot of money would make it
the money
honestly there's one
bad Barbie okay the bad baby baby
yeah he's like I'm gonna give it to her
I'm gonna give the 99 of them know but I
mean doesn't she make 50 million off of
like fully clothes
but to take it do you see what she said
she only done it as soon as she's only
gone to 18 is it is that what it is and
she said she only said this year she
thinks it's so
um what was the word she thinks it's
despicable the amount of men who
subscribed to her only found the series
I think it's deplorable I think he's
gross nasty I don't I don't even care if
his lingerie no offense it's just not my
thing but that's a lot of money that's
impressive yeah that's what I'm saying
is there is there a figure on money that
would make you respects
wait I don't think wait wait I don't
think respect is the right word I just
think it as a businessman okay do you
respect a cartel boss he makes billions
of dollars
but right like just because they make a
lot of money does money
no absolutely not money the love of
money is the root of all evil and so a
lot of women are selling their bodies
and their souls you have to go to sleep
at night and I'm sorry you're busting it
open and at some point like if if money
equal self-respect and respect there's
people who are billionaires that delete
themselves like these women have to go
to sleep at night how many how many
women have we seen Instagram models
right now I want any woman to think who
are the Instagram models busting it open
that or getting married that are men and
respecting and wifing up no they're
getting flown to Dubai to get busted
down for a camel and to get uh defecated
in the mouth oh wow
no no I mean we're speaking uh
scientific language here okay
is
there's documentaries these women are
doing this and and like I don't care how
much I would rather be homeless and
destitute than not to be able to sleep
at night knowing the things that I've
had to do now just one thing if you've
been violating this against your will
okay that's one thing and there's a lot
of women whose mind's been warped
because things have been done against
them against their world but that's not
the majority a lot of these women have a
love of money and they don't give a damn
what it means to anybody because money
is the only thing they want to buy bags
are they getting this money because they
want to build wells in Africa
and then they want to no they're
and the point is there is no respect
because you know what you're doing my
daughter see this that you you are
against wives you're against the women
who have put in the work to earn a
family tradition you have to earn a
family and so if you are a in the
street and you're busting it down open
and only fans you are the enemy of women
who are traditional and I'm sorry there
is is No Love in the just like you have
no love for me because you're going to
bust bust it open for my man and if a
dollar is going to pull you in that's
all you're worth is money you have no
intrinsic value like you there like you
have no morality you you don't believe
in anything but what you you can buy
Gucci and and whatever like I'm I'm
sorry there is no respect for that and I
don't mean it in a way to understand
women make decisions where they are but
at the same time somebody has to stand
up for Savannah James
LeBron James wife when she was on that
run on the Oscars you know you know she
she had she had two children out of
wetlock with LeBron James as as a
teenager her sons
but she made a different decision not to
go you know she stuck with a man and and
she made a different decision like there
are like who stands up for women who are
trying to do it right and right now I
feel like the dominant voice and culture
right now is women who are Horrors you
know don't judge me yes oh I'm judging
you so and I don't care like if you're
opening your your box for the street
like take everything that comes with it
don't demand respect when you don't
respect women you will take you will
entice that woman's husband and you
don't give a good goddamn what happens
to that family and what happens to them
but then you demand women to say respect
all this and other do you respect the
wives that have to deal with the BS that
you're doing and and and you and then
like just accept being bottom of the
barrel not only do they not respect the
wives but then they call the wives pick
me right right exactly
but they want all this respect but a
woman who wants to be a white
discovered the stuff he talked about
with men and how he tried to get men
together and I and I spoke about it
because he was a personal friend of mine
but you don't respect us but then you
want all this this respect but your
is open for consumption like no
you don't respect a wife you'll be ready
to be a side chick you will take that
man's money you will steal his you will
steal him from his wife you would do
whatever it takes to get a dollar and
because your mind is degraded and your
mind is gone and your mind has been
snatched into hell you're Middle Earth
and what's so crazy is that we have a
culture today period that supports that
like I was just down in Atlanta not too
long ago and there's a restaurant down
there I'm not going to name it because
they don't respond to me so they got
this new sandwich called the side chick
and they got Brittany Renner Brittany
Renner that will come in she'll come
through and she advertises because she's
a side chick football player years and
people that know her and they will say
and they don't care Hey listen and they
appropriate come to me and talk to me
about it and just like Brittany Arena
she's a six that's why we don't want her
she tried to get with us after the
podcast and we were just like oh
shots fired you know what I'm talking
about too you know
but you know who I'm talking about and
all these women yeah I do actually they
would go ham if they knew who it was and
he was like nah you a six chick I'm like
you got a mouth and you for the streets
I'm done listen but the culture it
supports it right so like mainstream
media is giving her money to promote her
being a side chick crystals no we don't
talk about that food restaurants no
advertising crazy though if a girl gets
married at 19 they'll say she's making a
terrible decision and she's two years
but she's a at 45 like Bernice
Burgos he's a grandmother and still out
there like look at my booty oh I'm that
like if you that fine and why don't you
have a husband yet like why are you this
fine this yourself
you're so special but look at these old
hoes they're sitting up and they're
still trying to get money like they are
grandmothers now busting it open for a
check you have to understand you men
it's not that you are less valuable as a
human being
but if you are you are putting yourself
in a position men do not respect you as
a way no man of value wants to bring a
known hoe
and as this is my wife and you're around
his boys and he's proud of you in
presenting you no you in the back room
he'll date you he'll you know what I'm
saying because you're a known hoe and
it's like okay we we all skied it and
skirted in this so it's my turn you know
say she was never yours it was just your
turn and so a lot of women as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible